news daily from science mission although
conversion of blood group A or B in 20
cells have been reported group whoa rhd
positive cells into negative cells
easier to be achieved researchers
convert our HD+ retro progenitor cells
into d- cells using transcription factor
like effector nucleases or talents
differentiated knockout clones did not
ignite innate in the presence of anti d
reagents and did not express the antigen
indicating successful conversion to be
negative cells next in response to
metabolic overload in the skeletal
muscle dj1 expression is upregulated
this prevents our OS or production and
maintains tight coupling of
mitochondrial respiration and ATP
generation consequently energy is
harvested efficiently from nutrient
sources leading to excess energy and
development of obesity and related
metabolic complications on the other
hand elevated roas induced by DJ 1
deficiency increase uncoupled
respiration and mitochondrial oxidation
thereby promoting fetal cell cycle
activity this leads to the activation of
ampk which enhances glycolysis and
glucose utilization these metabolic
effects together increase energy
expenditure in the skeletal muscle and
confirm resistance to obesity and type 2
diabetes for more news visitors at ww
science mission calm or science mission
facebook page thanks for watching